such a new game against blackburn 2005 from
the netherlands has like me about
2400 mine also never played against them let's
see
how
we can get my
luggage back or modern defense
structure
who's always relieved when the
opponents are so slow at least at the
beginning with
aha i'm with c5 most of the seats
already with marriage from ford
was in itself that's fine with me
46 a bit strange about that i
don't know exactly what his parts he
wants to go with
i would like to look at the 15
times
that
may be a strange
one  seventh game
but all of that is very very suspicious
everything
played roughly like that on a computer
not at all white and wrong the
moves reproduced
strange game in any case